do you consider yourself a writer more  than an actor because i you always talk  about writing and you always talk about  like you could always write yourself out  of trouble do you always carry that in  your head yeah i mean it's part it's  definitely part of  how i think about myself yes it's it's  it's a hugely important part of you know  actually when i did the departed uh i  was i was in this rehearsal  uh in in pre-production and it was just  me and jack nicholson and scorsese and  at one point marty got up to either use  the bathroom or have a cup of coffee or  something  and it was just me and jack in the room  and he turned around and he goes out of  nowhere he goes you know i never would  have made it this far in my career if i  wasn't a great [ __ ] writer  really yeah out of out of nowhere and it  was like everything clicked into place  and i went of course like how do you  have a 40-year career right it's because  he was a great writer